et nous sommes avec didier fagard
membres de l'association france
palestine solidarité bonjour bonjour
merci d'être avec nous alors comment
vous réagissez à la publication de cette
liste par l'onu sur des entreprises qui
continuent de commercer illégalement
donc avec les colonies israéliennes en
cisjordanie alors on réagit d'abord
positivement c'est à dire qu'en fait
c'est une bonne nouvelle
une bonne nouvelle pour le droit
international pour l'application de ce
droit
peut-être faut-il rajouter deux mots
pour vos téléspectateurs pour rappelé
que cette le conseil des droits de
l'homme en une minute et c'est un organe
de l'onu qui a été créée donc en 2006
qui a 47 membres élus pour trois ans
c'est à dire à peu près un quart de
l'ensemble en fait des pays qui
participent à l'onu sur deux roues aussi
sur l'histoire de cette liste vous avez
rappelé tout à l'heure le fait que
c'était un rapport de 2016 une décision
de 2016 du conseil des droits de l'homme
faut savoir qu'avant ce 2016 il ya eu en
2013 un rapport qui a été fait sur en
fait la situation donc dans le
territoire palestinien occupé et les
effets de la colonisation
les effets sont accablants sont
désastreux et ce qui est intéressant
c'est lorsque ce rapport en 2013 avait
été approuvé par 46 voix sur 47 le seul
qui n'avait pas voté pour c'était les
états unis et en 2016
lorsque la décision donc a été prise de
d'établir cette base de données des
entreprises qui pas seulement commerces
qui ont des activités en fait qui
implique les les colonies cette décision
a été prise à l'époque avec seulement 32
voix et 15 abstentions
c'est à dire que la communauté
internationale est quelque fois un petit
peu moins courageuse quand il s'agit de
prendre des décisions effectives
non mais vous l'avez bien préciser c
le haut-commissariat justement de l'onu
ce n'est pas le conseil de sécurité en
tout cas il n'y a pas là une volonté de
dénoncer les colonies israéliennes en
cisjordanie
si il ya bien j'allais dire cette
décision elle se place aussi dans le
droit ligne d'autres décisions du
conseil de sécurité notamment la
décision la résolution en 23 34 du
conseil de sécurité de décembre 2016 qui
a bien dit en fait dans son premier
article
en fait l'illégalité de façon
extrêmement ferme des colonies
israéliennes et qui essaie le poids
important dans son points 5/10 que
l'ensemble des états membres en fait
doivent différencier impérativement à la
façon notice comporte avec israël et
avec l'été les colonies dans les
territoires occupés
donc si c'est bien une décision si vous
voulez qui se situe dans le droit fil en
fait des décisions du conseil de
sécurité
la suite ce sera quoi après la
publication lors de ce la suite si vous
voulez ce qui est important c'est que
donc les cette publication intervient
que trois ans quatre ans après la
décision
ça a été long il ya eu énormément de
pression en fait pour empêcher la
publication de cette liste
elle est donc sorti aujourd'hui il faut
savoir d'abord que c'est une première
liste il ya 112 entreprises si on
l'avait 300 à peu près qui ont été
analysés et cette liste elle va faire
l'objet d'ajouts et de retrait
l'objectif numéro un c'est de demander
aux entreprises de respecter le droit
international de respecter les droits de
l'homme
en fait dans une région de ses droits de
l'homme sont bafoués
en fait en permanence à venir de ces
c'est donc leur activité ça veut dire de
cesser leurs habitués alors ses
activités variées dans les jardins ni
tout à fait c'est qu'il ya 112 sociétés
qui sont qui ont été listées dans ses
112 sociétés l'essentiel son destin
israélienne et c'est bien normal ce sont
des banques
ce sont des sociétés qui rendent des
services en matière de télécoms en
matière d'eau en matière d christ etc et
des sociétés étrangères
il ya à peu près donc il ya tout à fait
d'ailleurs 18 sociétés étrangères qui
sont listées dont 6 américaine et trois
françaises les trois françaises c'est
des sociétés alstom et egis legis reiki
est un groupe d'ingénierie un peu moins
connus qui et pourquoi est ce qu'ils
sont cités parce qu'en fait ils ont
participé
cette façon directe à la construction du
tramway à jérusalem un travail illégal
qui passe de jérusalem-ouest ça on n'a
rien à dire mais qui va de l'autre côté
vers jérusalem est pour desservir les
colonies donc ce qu'est mis en cause à
travers ça si vous voulez c'est le fait
que des entreprises donc étrangères
aussi ont des activités en fait avec la
colonisation et contribuer à cette
scolarisation michel d'acheter à lèvres
haut commissaire aux droits de l'homme
de l'onu donc indique quand même que
cette liste ne va pas servir de boycott
en tout cas de prétexte à boycotter ces
entreprises qui sont listées
la question des sanctions est ce que
c'est pas justement un point qui manque
là précisément ces on est dans le cadre
du droit international les cadets du
manque quelquefois de ses moyens j'ai à
dire d'actions effectivement
opérationnel mais pour l'occasion si
vous voulez tout un certain nombre de
ces sociétés sont bien connus nous en
tant que l'association militante avec
les organisations des droits de l'homme
avec les organisations syndicales
on a déjà mené tout un certain nombre
d'actions notamment sur le tramway
jérusalem j'évoquais egis alstom il ya
une troisième société qui s'appelait
systra lors de on a mené des actions
contre orange à l'époque en 2015 qui ont
abouti à son retrait on a mené des
opérations contre safege une société
filiale de suez et on a mis en cause
aussi tout un certain nombre de banques
françaises parce que dans la liste là
qui est publié les sociétés israéliennes
disait il ya beaucoup de banques à la
dizaine de grandes banques israéliennes
qui sont présentes
l'objectif maintenant ça va être de
faire aussi que les banques françaises
est une société d'assurance axa ne
finisse par ces banques israéliennes
parce qu'en finançant les banques
israéliennes et financé indirectement la
colonie donc on s'attendait peut-être
une réaction ainsi d'israël après la
médiation les réactions d'israël on les
a eus on les a entendus c'est une
reddition 2 c et c
elles sont sans surprise habituellement
je pense que dès lors qu'on rappelle le
tronc international malheureusement
aujourd'hui au gouvernement israélien
la réponse est toujours en fait que
c'est malvenu
ce droit international pearson
l'appliquent etc merci tu dis fagard
d'avoir répondu en direct à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
membre de l'association france palestine
solidarité vous